today I think it's an exciting time to
be Irish according to surveys the Irish
are amongst the happiest people in
Europe and the most optimistic about the
future in the European Union you have
managed to combine fidelity with the
past with a freedom from all anxieties
at the 60th anniversary of the treaties
which laid the foundations for the EU I
said in Rome Europe as a political
entity will either be United or will not
be at all only a united Europe can be a
sovereign Europe in relation to the rest
of the world
and only a sovereign Europe guarantees
independence for its Nations guarantees
freedom for its citizens
I don't like brexit actually that's an
understatement
I believe breaks it is one of the
saddest moments in 21st century European
history in fact sometimes I am even
furious about it and my main focus will
be to to eliminate or at least reduce
negative side effects of brexit with the
Irish question of course in the centre
of my attention I'm really obsessed with
the European unity but at the same time
I am NOT a federalist I don't believe in
one European nation or one European
super-state
today we need to be more cautious with
dreams and more affect different comes
to act what I feel today is that if you
want to integrate Europe more and more
we have to guarantee today security or
at least a feeling of security for all
the citizens